[Musique]
Edward Bernays a été l'un des fondateurs
du domaine des relations publiques ou, comme
il l'appelait au début de sa carrière, de la
propagande, il a commencé à le faire très
tôt au XXe siècle pendant
la Première Guerre mondiale, il faisait partie du
Bureau de la propagande de guerre.  connu sous le nom de
Comité de l'information publique ou de la
Commission de creel la persuasion
ou les relations publiques auparavant avaient été
l'œuvre de journalistes en d'autres termes
faisons en sorte que cela sonne comme des nouvelles donnons le
goût des nouvelles donnons l'impression que cela ressemble
à des nouvelles
Bernays a estimé que le fait synonyme  d'
eux-mêmes n'avaient pas d'importance il croyait
que les gens étaient poussés par l'instinct par
leur inconscient par des appels irrationnels
il croyait aussi que le système médiatique
fournissait des voies ferrées le
long desquelles les idées pouvaient être pompées et
qu'il était nécessaire d'atteindre la
vie intérieure des gens leur vie inconsciente
leur  instincts leur moelle épinière
afin de pouvoir amener le public à
accepter les actions exécutives que vous
souhaitez  prendre
[Music]
quand vous parlez de fabricant de
consentement ou de manipulation de consentement intégré
dans ces phrases est l'idée qu'il
y a ces ingénieurs invisibles qui
se tiennent dans les coulisses et aident à
façonner l'accord des gens sur les politiques
qui sont décidées par d'autres
personnes  donc, d'un autre côté, je pense
que la réception démocratique du MOC est possible,
il doit y avoir un
va-et-vient continu de persuasion et je pense
que sans un public capable de
s'engager et de prendre en charge les problèmes qui
affectent leur vie  et être le plus
informé à leur sujet au lieu de chercher
des experts tout le temps c'est ce
genre de situation qui fera que le
consentement viendra d'un accord plutôt
que d'une manipulation
[Musique]
le fabricant du consentement
s'appuie en grande partie sur l'idée d'
individualisme  en d'autres termes que chaque
personne est une unité isolée et si vous
pouvez comprendre comment appuyer sur le bouton pour
ce sentiment d'isolement et vous pouvez en
fait encourager ce sens  séduire l'
exaltation et encourager la peur et le
dégoût qui accompagnent ce sentiment
d'isolement, alors vous les avez dans
votre main, mais d'abord un conseil que je
donnerais à quelqu'un est d'arrêter d'être
quelqu'un parce que tant que vous êtes seul
en tant que personne, à certains égards, vous
ne faites pas partie d'un public démocratique engagé,
donc je pense qu'une partie de ce qui doit arriver
est que le public devienne un public et
pas seulement une agglomération de l'éducation de quelqu'un
est la clé dont les gens ont besoin pour
comprendre l'histoire de  persuasion dont
ils ont besoin de connaître l'histoire de la façon dont les
grandes guerres ont été vendues aux gens dont ils ont
besoin de connaître l'histoire de la façon dont les
grands dirigeants sont devenus les grands
dirigeants même si beaucoup d'entre eux ne
méritaient pas d'être et en fait nous '  Réagir
contre les meilleurs intérêts de la
personne ordinaire,
c'est quand une forme de communication où la
persuasion laisse les gens moins conscients
du monde qu'ils ne l'étaient avant de l'
expérimenter, alors c'est quelque chose
qui est une menace parce que faire des gens  l'
inconscient est l'un des systèmes de base de la
règle par contre si vous développez des
outils de persuasion qui amènent les gens à être
plus conscients et plus compréhensifs du
monde qui les entoure c'est pour moi une utilisation très
progressive et positive il n'y a
rien de mal à la persuasion aussi longtemps  comme
cela se déroule sur un pied d'égalité
et n'est pas contrôlé par l'argent et qui
a son mot à dire n'est pas contrôlé par l'argent
il y a toujours des intérêts et c'est
toujours un intérêt là toujours c'est tout
personne n'est un observateur neutre l'idée d'
informations objectives l'idée  que d'une manière ou d'une autre, les
nouvelles sont quelque chose qui a été cultivé dans un
tube à essai par un scientifique en blouse blanche
c'est une illusion et aucune agence de
presse aucun conteur bien que les
journalistes devraient pouvoir se cacher
derrière l'idée qu'il n'y a pas d'
intérêts impliqués car il y a
toujours  l'intérêt dont vous avez besoin pour ce qui
doit être évalué est qui profite à qui est
blessé
il n'y a pas de norme neutre c'est le
résultat de statistiques et l'une des
choses  Ce que les statisticiens savent, c'est que
même si vous pouvez définir la norme, le
neutre que la réalité est composée de nombreuses
positions différentes et aussi
quelle est la qualité de l'information
qui est présentée et ce
qui peut être coché
en d'autres termes  si vous avez un public qui
est prêt à creuser creuser ils doivent
je peux j'essaie juste de ne pas le faire parce qu'ils peuvent
voir que l'extrait sonore fait partie du problème
l'extrait sonore fait partie du problème
c'est-à-dire que je comprends ce que vous
cherchez  ouais tu sais je sais comment
éditer je sais de quoi il s'agit
je sais comment voir comment tout fonctionne et
particulièrement si tu cherches quatre
pièces de trois minutes ou trois pièces de quatre minutes
alors tu ne veux pas qu'il se passe trop de
choses là-bas  juste parce que ce n'est
qu'une partie du problème, c'est que les
structures mêmes des médias et c'est
quelque chose qui doit être abordé
et c'est la façon même dont l'
information est structurée, ce n'est pas que
ce n'est pas idéal, c'est que cela décourage  s
pensait que cela décourage la nuance, cela
décourage d'une part et d'
autre part parce que vous parlez de
quelque chose comme l'avantage comme la
rhétorique aux États-Unis et en
anglais la rhétorique signifie mentir
aujourd'hui mais la rhétorique concerne aussi la
capacité de présenter des connaissances  des
idées d'information et une vision du monde d'une manière qui n'est pas
simplement une liste de faits sans sang.
Je n'essaie pas de refaire le monde ici,
je comprends juste le problème, mais vous
savez qu'un bon montage peut prendre de petits
extraits de biens
[Musique]